[Música]
bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
reporteros en france 24 cierro blanco
como siempre un gusto saludarlos
comenzamos la economía libanesa está
agonizando sin embargo sigue manteniendo
a gotas a un vecino incómodo la siria de
bachar al asad con la aplicación de
sanciones internacionales en particular
la ley cesar que entró en vigor en eeuu
en el año 2020 el tráfico
transfronterizo entre líbano y siria se
ha disparado esta ley prohíbe cualquier
transacción con empresas e instituciones
vinculadas al líder de siria ya su
entorno reporteros lo lleva esta semana
por las rutas del contrabando en el
corazón de la crisis económica libanesa
james andrew y mais agua han investigado
un fenómeno que le cuesta a la economía
libanesa varios millones de dólares al
día e impide que la comunidad
internacional acuda en ayuda del país
del señor
[Música]
los guardaespaldas de kennedy se
preparan para una salida en la frontera
[Música]
las armas son los adornos de los hombres
mediante la ausencia del estado
hay que defenderse
amar nasreddine
es la cabeza de una de las familias más
poderosas de la región de gm el en el
líbano
una región fronteriza con siria y
gangrenada por el contrabando
una salida familiar
con las hijas y los hijos de cheikh
rodeado de descuentos
[Música]
estamos en la carretera hacia el pueblo
el caso host shahid ali en la frontera
siria
verán el tráfico con sus propios ojos
los habitantes de la región de gérmenes
se quejan de estar abandonados por el
estado de libanés
aquí no hay ni hospital ni universidad y
una ley antidrogas de 1990 privó a la
región de su principal recurso toda esta
tierra le pertenece a nuestra familia
dos más red y nos hace 15 20 años todo
esto eran campos de cannabis la gente
vivía bien en aquella época pagaban
impuestos sus facturas de electricidad
ahora no tienen nada que perder
al final de esta carretera una primera
bandera siria
y soldados leales al gobierno de bashar
al-assad
[Música]
este es el ejército sirio se les llama
los llanes son los guardias de la
frontera
no hay aduanas ni señalización
sin embargo abandonamos líbano y estamos
en el territorio sirio esta carretera
que va a lo largo del canal es uno de
los puntos más activos del tráfico entre
los dos países
el baile de las motos y de los 4x4 con
ventanas polarizadas es incesante frente
al ejército sirio dispuesto cada 100
metros la frontera está cerrada debido
al coronavirus el régimen sirio está
bajo sanciones internacionales y eeuu
impone la ley césar que prohíbe toda
transacción con empresas e instituciones
relacionadas con bashar al-assad y su
entorno oficialmente nada debería pasar
por aquí amar nos conduce a un terreno
que posee cerca al canal
[Música]
los llevamos a la frontera verán todo lo
que está siendo tramitada vamos antes de
que los contrabandistas huyan
[Música]
este es el río así separa a líbano de
siria miren a los gillán es los guardas
de la frontera siria se pueden ver la
operación está en curso allá en el
puente los vehículos se estacionan ahí
la carga
vi la luz
los traficantes vieron nuestra cámara
no quieren ser grabados huyendo que
temen a las cámaras porque lo que hacen
es ilegal pero yo no considero que lo
que ocurre sea ilegal son libaneses a
unos sirios libaneses
en estas regiones las familias viven
entre la frontera hace generaciones
pasar de un país a otro mercancías es
natural
no es nada es un poco de combustible una
pipeta de gas antes del tráfico no es
eso lo que arruinará a un estado que se
respeta y respeta a su pueblo en vez de
crear fábricas para que haya trabajo nos
juzgan y nos prueban de alimento que
tenemos que hacer solo deben proponer
una alternativa
s
trata de minimizar
pero algunas redes de traficantes
invierten mucho para atraer mucha
cantidad a la frontera es una estación
de gasolina están construyendo la en la
frontera
pueden vivir y traficar no se van a
probar
el combustible es entregado legalmente
del lado libanés antes de ser traficados
hacia silla la carretera atraviesa de
nuevo esta frontera porosa hacia el
líbano el pueblo alcázar es una placa
giratoria del contrabando
y un territorio de los partidos chiítas
amal y hezbollah que dios bendiga el
alma del general suleimán y larga vida a
nasralá nos devolvieron nuestra dignidad
nuestra fuerza
aquí hay camiones enteros de mercancías
este camión es tráfico le podemos hablar
hablaremos con los conductores en la
carretera un poco más lejos pero aquí
aquí tienen miedo la carretera serpentea
hacia el norte
y otros puntos de paso ubicados en los
360 kilómetros de frontera común con
sirio
por nuestra solicitud
el cheikh se informa sobre el cargamento
de los camiones
[Música]
disimulamos nuestra cámara
no tengas miedo
de dónde vienes de sal en el norte al
personal qué haces aquí transporto
ovejas que transportes un vehículo a una
carcasa de vehículo cuál es tu carga era
que dios te dé fuerza
y se verá una parte va al norte de
líbano y otra ver siria si hay una
diferencia de precio aprovecha ese es su
trabajo se trafica de todo en especial
de productos subsidiados por el estado
libanés como ovejas y heno y los
traficantes no corren mucho riesgo son
transferidos al ministerio público
financiero
libres
sucede todo el tiempo
solicitamos regresar por siria y la
carretera del canal de regreso los
traficantes son más activos descargan
camiones enteros frente a los guardas de
la frontera
lo hacen frente a todo el mundo
la economía siria bajo embargo
se desangra tras 10 años de guerra
los soldados no tienen ningún interés en
impedir el tráfico
la verdad
más nada caliente
[Música]
en esta oportunidad nuestra presencia
incómoda que temen más a las cámaras de
las armas en lo que a la ley
[Música]
el traficante prefirió no generar una
guerra con él
reding
y
líbano enfrenta a una tormenta económica
los efectos del tráfico en la frontera
se suman a la corrupción a la crisis
política y a la fuga de capitales todo
el país está afectado
incluido a beirut
la capital
la libra libanesa se desplomó perdió el
90% de su valor el pueblo está furioso
cada día grupos de manifestantes
bloquean las carreteras por todo el país
qué espera el presidente aún debe
abandonar su cargo en vez de acusarnos
de hampones tiene que ver que no lo
somos que tenemos hambre y él es el
culpable está cerrado a su silla es hora
de que se vayan
en casa somos seis y el dólar superó las
diez mil 500 libras libanesas cómo vamos
a vivir perdón pero debemos robar
los poderosos se alimentan porque todo
se va a siria no encontramos azúcar
faltan muchos productos no hay alimentos
ni medicamentos
no tenemos nada que perder se terminó
solo tenemos juego o arreglamos nuestro
problema en nuestra rabia se consumirá
punto final
el poder adquisitivo de los libaneses
está en caída libre a principios de 2020
el salario mínimo era el equivalente a
450 dólares hoy en día está alrededor de
y la tasa de cambio fluctúa
permanentemente
real es el director de marketing de esta
tienda ubicada en la periferia norte de
beirut un barrio de clase media está en
primera línea frente a la frustración de
los clientes
la economía leonesa está dolarizada es
decir que todo es importado al pagado en
dólares en función de la tasa de cambio
y la tasa cambia todo el tiempo en la
mañana en la tarde y en la noche
es el vals de las etiquetas los precios
ya no se muestran en la tienda la
inflación está explotando
mira el precio
paso a 19.800 libras libanesas estamos
perdiendo el país nos estamos
derrumbando están robando todo
pobre león para calmar el descontento el
gobierno subsidia desde hace un año el
combustible y una canasta de 300
productos básicos lo cual cuesta 500
millones de dólares mensuales sin
embargo hay escasez y las tiendas se ven
obligadas a racionar
lo que está subsidiado son las lentejas
el futuro y el arroz es todo no hay
aceite shampoos detergente una vida
miserable
me debo alimentar ocho bocas y esto es
todo lo que puedo comprar somos ocho en
casa esto no es nada para hoy aquí están
los productos subsidiados
me gustaría subsidiarles una sola ida al
infierno a todos los que desvían la
mercancía a mí este grandes ciudades
las tiendas y los mayoristas son
acusados de almacenar los productos
subsidiados para especular o traficar al
extranjero
son 93 mil 500 voy a ver si tengo
suficientes
cuando veo camiones enteros que se van
al extranjero a plena luz del día sin
que nadie controle por supuesto que me
preocupo y aún hay productos disponibles
mañana tal vez no haya nada
la gente se abalanza sobre la ley
estiman pt mírenla ya no hay
también el azúcar y el aceite
la gente busca sus productos desaparecen
de inmediato ya no tiene leche sobres en
polvo ya no hay porque los tiene
almacenados no para nada ya no hay ok lo
siento
la escasez causa tensiones y varias
tiendas han sido atacadas
hoy de personas ingresaron a la tienda
de la fuerza dañaron todo atacaron al
personal de texas tiraron la mercancía
el piso acusándonos de esconder los
productos subsidiados
no almacenamos los puntos subsidiados no
recibimos de los mayoristas y ellos
permanecen media hora en nuestra bodega
mientras etiquetamos antes de vender
está todo en 30 minutos para el barco
luego se venden 3 minutos la gente
espera sus productos tiene hambre con
otro la lancha
le mostramos estas imágenes a jake
nasreddine en la sala de su casa me
duele ver que nosotros los libaneses
estemos viviendo esto todo esto por un
sobre de leche para hacer subsidiar
que dios los ayude qué quiere que le
diga si estamos en esto ya no hay
esperanza en ella pero se le acusa de
ser el responsable del hambre porque
usted trafica los productos subsidiados
que dios perdone a los que dicen eso
nosotros empobrecemos al líbano activa
no acaba de anunciar su quiebra pero en
realidad estamos quebrados desde hace
años lo hicimos para acabar con las
finanzas del estado los que reinan desde
hace 30 años son conocidos por robar el
dinero del estado
el tráfico existe desde hace decenios en
siria la ley césar causó una crisis
social y económica más grave que aquí
son nuestros padres si tienen hambre
también nosotros y viceversa las
fronteras están abiertas y las aduanas
ausentes son ellas las que deberían
controlar el tráfico
ejército patrulla
trata de parar el tráfico y confisca
vehículos camiones enteros con su carga
épica última ue
[Música]
estos camiones cisternas llenos de miles
de litros de gasolina y gas esperan para
pasar el puesto de control es dejar bat
a la puerta de entrada hacia el norte
germen y la frontera según las
estimaciones de más del 60% de los
combustibles subsidiados por el estado
de libanés son traficados hacia siria
[Música]
el ejército libanés tiene puestos de
control en la frontera como aquí al
norte de casa
dame tus papeles quieres la factura si
la factura se queda en la estación de
gasolina siempre se quedan con ella
el soldado debe dejar que el camión
continúe su combustible ha sido enviado
a una estación de gasolina ubicada del
lado libanés a lo largo de la frontera
imposible saber si la mercancía será
traficada hacia siria por
apague el motor
este punto de control es fijo y conocido
por los traficantes que toman sus
precauciones
aquí el ejército libanés marca su
presencia
pero el verdadero trabajo de lucha
contra el tráfico se hace de manera más
discreta el ejército está desplegado en
los puntos sensibles que dominan los
valles y nueve leves que permiten
observación sol
este es un puesto del ejército libanés
domina el valle cada movimiento es
detectado que hay ahora que recibimos de
inmediato un mensaje cuando hay un
movimiento sospechoso que está a robert
algunos otros patrullamos las 24 horas
significamos de inmediato el ataque
miembro
el terreno es accidentado es fácil
esconderse entonces debemos patrullar a
pie para garantizar que no haya
traficantes u personas buscadas
anaya mota de viento
late
para buscar
antes de la revolución el tráfico iba a
decirle al imán después del inicio de la
crisis siria el sentido del tráfico
cambio de nuestro lado al censura en
especial combustible productos
subsidiados harina hemos incautado
grandes cantidades de productos y los
hemos devuelto a las autoridades
competentes
el trabajo del ejército libanés es aún
más difícil porque a una parte de la
clase política tiene interés en dejar
que sucedan las cosas
todo el mundo debe despertar la gente
tiene hambre y a nuestros responsables
no les importa
el presidente debe irse
en vivo
las manifestaciones y los bloqueos
continúan
ya no hay medicinas no hay paracetamol
no hay vitamina c canta para bocas
cuesta 4.000 libras todas las medicinas
son traficadas hacia el extranjero todo
se va syrian y se esconden bueno no no
se pasa por aquí está cerrado
retrocedamos
dormir en la calle no me moveré y pasar
la noche aquí
[Música]
hay productos traficados hacia si bien
no se esconden sabemos quién está detrás
de todo esto te lo digo es tiradero es
irán quien dirige el país el estado
persa dirigen nuestro país hay que decir
las cosas como son
nuestro parlamento está a las órdenes de
los iraníes que manejan toda la
corrupción el tráfico en línea dr
es el hezbollah y el partido a más ellos
tienen el poder y nos controlan nadie
más
la implicación en 2013 de hezbollah en
una guerra siria profundizó las
divisiones en líbano
y alejo el país de sus aliados árabes y
occidentales la carretera que conduce a
su sede en el sur está decorada con
colores del partido de dios chiíta y pro
iraní
el pueblo de ánzar es uno de sus
bastiones numerosos jóvenes de esta
región no fueron a combatir al lado del
ejército de bachar al asad no hay cifras
oficiales pero se estima que varios
miles de combatientes de hezbollah
pasaron la frontera un gran número de
ellos jamás regresó
nuestro pueblo de ánsar arballo perdió a
cuatro mártires en la defensa sagrada
durante la guerra encima de su río
uno de ellos era mohamed el hijo de
nawal
está enterrado aquí
vengo todos los jueves y hablo le cuento
mi jornada que elche es creo que me
responde que escucha y no a mi los
mártires siguen vivos a la y
los hornets
la casa de nawal parece un mausoleo a la
gloria de su hijo
nos lo hace visitar
yo les ofrecí a mi hijo le dije que dios
esté contigo y él fue combatió y gracias
a dios se llevó la victoria un canal
univisión
breve que hezbollah ganó la guerra
no quiero burlarme pero sí claro que
ganamos claro forma
estamos
la fe no hay victoria sin pagar un
precio de sangre no hay victoria sin
sacrificio no existe sin mártires no se
puede ser victorioso tener dignidad y
honor en una bandeja de plata
nosotros estamos con bachar al asad está
con nosotros
jugar cada persona pasar al otro que
apoya el eje de la resistencia y nuestra
dignidad y honor amo estamos con él y la
resistencia no caerá para terminar le
digo siempre estaremos presentes nadie
puede contenerlos en la con
nos están haciendo una guerra económica
la tasa del dólar que no es del estado
que se está derrumbando es política
están combatiendo la resistencia creando
ideas y así es todo lo que ocurre en
líbano
guerra contra nosotros lo usan por todo
pero no tendremos hambre si no está ahí
comeremos piedras de ser necesario sol
calor
los combates se han calmado en siria
pero hezbollah siempre está presente
militarmente
elche y que sabe que él nabulsi
es un religioso chiíta fue designado por
el partido para responder a nuestras
preguntas para él para hacerle frente a
las sanciones occidentales
la lucha se ubica en el terreno
económico
es un cambio de estrategia en lugar de
ejercer presiones militares ejercen una
presión económica total lo hacen porque
su proyecto militar en siria fracasó el
fi sur ya salió hoy en día nosotros y
siria somos objeto de una guerra
distinta a ratley habana trabajamos para
que verán heart
este aceite económico mediante acuerdos
con países afectadas
artest y emergentes que tienen
influencia a nivel internacional como
renuncia y tshabalala emilia se llama
rusia o así
en este contexto
hezbollah considera el contrabando como
el legítimo
claro claro el tráfico hace parte de la
resistencia para defender los intereses
de los libaneses del mono y lo que
ocurre hoy en día
bajo la presión estadounidense y las
sanciones actuales a nadie que es que
los dos pueblos libaneses y sirios están
obligados a pasar la frontera así y
agarran el transgredir las reglas para
responder a sus necesidades ayer también
hasta ya tienen almas y sin embargo el
partido niega cualquier implicación
directa en el tráfico
sería mentir decir que es escuela
aprovechada de estos productos
subsidiados
aguayo arriba y los tránsfugas y así
andan quienes han hecho el dinero son
los poderosos comerciantes y quienes
tienen cargos en el estado libanés esta
ola alemania no le puede pedir a
hezbollah que cuide las fronteras y
detengan a los traficantes alemana al
mojar rybin es la responsabilidad de los
servicios de seguridad y en especial el
ejército libanés le dijo a manía de
vania con baja del hardware
regreso a la frontera con el ejército
libanés
los soldados siguen jugando al gato y al
ratón con redes de traficantes de bien
armados y organizados que desaparecen
cuando pasa el ejército
[Música]
entonces
pierre ménard el mundo
pues
canción
retomamos la carretera a lo largo del
canal
aire león
a llevar a la seguridad
los soldados no pueden intervenir del
otro lado de la frontera diez años
después del inicio de la guerra en siria
estos militares están en la primera
línea de una nueva batalla geopolítica
que se libra en las fronteras libanesas
por un lado el régimen de bashar
al-assad aprovecha el contrabando y la
complacencia de sus aliados para
esquivar las sanciones por otro lado los
occidentales exigen que el líbano le
ponga fin al tráfico antes de ayudarle
de lo contrario estarían sacando a flote
al régimen que tratan de sancionar entre
los dos el pueblo libanés asiste
impotente a la expoliación de su
economía en beneficio de su incómodo
vecino
y de esta manera llegamos al final de
esta misión de reporteros a el
documental en france 24 continuar con
nosotros hasta una próxima oportunidad
[Música]